every day the perishable goods are
packed up for transport harvest fresh
supplies large supermarket chains with
vegetables grown on the company's own
fields and nearby farms
driver lucky fan Feeny is preparing his
cargo who met that implement today he's
taking it to a big warehouse in
Johannesburg
the truck interior has to reach the
required temperature before the delicate
Freight can be loaded
final instructions from the logistics
manager so 15 you get to decline but you
the vegetables have to be kept cool at a
constant temperature of two point seven
degrees Celsius during the transport
that will be checked on delivery we need
to make sure that everything is back
directly sealed correctly because any
they say any eaten stuff that comes in
your to the vegetables that are not
sealed properly not cooled properly goes
to waste refrigerated transport is
important in a hot country like South
Africa this is one of the thirteen
thousand or so refrigerated trucks in
the country the fleet emits enormous
amounts of greenhouse gases the cargo
area of most trucks is poorly insulated
resulting in greater diesel fuel
consumption and spoiled produce South
Africa's agency for Standards the S abs
wants to make refrigerated transports
more climate-friendly a testing hall for
the refrigerated trucks was recently
opened here the first on the African
continent Germany's agency for
international development cooperation
the GIC supported the construction of
the hall by making contacts to companies
that operate similar testing facilities
in Europe the technology had to be
adapted for use in South Africa a lot of
tips on how to do how to set up but the
main thing that I also say
transport vehicles here are bigger and
more powerful than they are in Europe at
the moment only one out of five
manufacturers meets the minimum
standards for insulation for the first
time ever the new facility allows
testers here to precisely determine just
how well the trucks are insulated there
was no exact data available up to now
that gives a tool to all the
manufacturers to improve the insulation
properties that can actually see that
they reaction the practical performance
of the improvements that they have made
so that they can implement that into
production hours with a lot of new
tracks out there with better insulation
we know we will use less diesel to run
the cooling systems less diesel means
less carbon emissions into the
atmosphere every vehicle tested here
gets an environmental seal before long
the seal will be required on all
vehicles that transport fresh produce
abroad it tells how much fuel the
vehicle needs for refrigeration and
gives the values measured by the
temperature sensors in the testing
chamber correct
entering Johannesburg lucky thanthe a
knee has been on the road with this
vegetable truck for about an hour and a
half a special coolant helps maintain
the low temperature in the cargo area
most refrigerated trucks use this
coolant which contains a chemical that
is harmful to the environment its impact
on the atmosphere is four thousand times
greater than co2
[Music]
the trans fridge company plans on
switching to another refrigerant the
company has developed this prototype
that will soon hit the market it says
it's the world's only cooling system
that uses propane while minimizing the
risk of using the flammable substance
okay that's fine
we use propane because it is totally
environmentally friendly it does nothing
to the ozone layer its carbon footprint
is very small and that is why we chose
propane and it's also very easily
obtainable using propane can sink
coolant emissions by a factor of a
thousand trans fridge tested its
prototype in this truck in the summer it
transports ice cream cooled to minus 25
degrees Celsius
the company plans to produce five to ten
further propane based cooling units here
in the coming months and to test them on
the road and put the final touches on
the new technology
the cooling unit can be powered by a
small motor that saves on fuel costs if
everything works out as planned
the conventional environmentally harmful
coolant will no longer be used here the
company wants to install the propane
technology in all refrigeration units
for large medium and small vehicles then
we will look at exporting to the local
African markets Zambia Zimbabwe Namibia
Botswana Mozambique revealed we have a
very good presence in all those markets
and once it's proven here we will
introduce it into those Marcus experts
estimate that by 2030 South Africa can
reduce its co2 emissions by two million
tonnes alone through better insulation
and propane based cooling units
it's a first step towards making South
Africa's refrigerated transport climate
friendly and that is urgently needed to
sustain the sector's rapid growth
you
you